I know you must get harassed by the
paparazzi and and you have this
reputation of being a very nice guy
there was actually there was an article
that was written about Hollywood stars
and how willing they are and generous
they are to give an autograph and you
came in like the top 5 in terms of
willing to spend time with people be
kind to them give them an autograph
which i think is a very nice quality to
have but you also get I'm imagine
hounded a lot right yeah well there's a
difference right so there's there's the
people who genuinely come up and say hey
could I please have a picture or an
autograph or whatever and it you know or
take a picture with my kid and yeah I
would never say no to anybody like that
and then there's a whole there's a
professional autograph set right and
there and they're trying to make a
living and I had this idea so they show
up they've got like a stack of 100 or
200 pictures and they and they will and
as long as you sign a there they want
you to sign as many as you possibly can
right because they sell each one yeah
and so I've always had a really good
rapport with those guys and I'm always
like you know who's the most you know I
remember when I first started out I was
fascinated by these guys and I'd go like
what's the bet what if you could get one
autograph you know and I'm signing away
if you could get one autograph what
would it be Elizabeth Taylor it was oh
if I could get an Elizabeth Taylor I've
how much is Elizabeth Taylor work well
she never signs so she's worth you know
five thousand dollars if you get a
picture signed by her and IV you know
well what am i worth and they'd be like
twenty bucks and they always shoot me
straight which is great and I go okay
well I just signed ten of them so that's
two hundred bucks okay so that's alright
so we're good for today but uh but you
start to realize the more you sign well
my idea right so I had this kind of
failed calculus Ben Affleck and I talked
about this cuz it's all started for us
at the same time and we were like what
if we could saturate the marketplace
right like what if we could drive the
price down to like eight bucks right
right and then we wouldn't be worth it
like nobody's gonna show up and get your
picture cuz it's like I can't even get a
movie ticket so and then you just be
left with the actual true fans so that
was our that was our plan but it never
it never really worked and I just ended
up signing thousands I think the floor
is like 20 bucks yeah yeah yeah I'm
always amazed when someone sees you go
into a restaurant like I've had this
happen you go into a restaurant you eat
your food you're not even there that
long and you come out and the person in
that time has managed to get a picture
of you yeah they somehow have a way of
figuring out oh I just saw Conan go into
that place and within like 20 minutes
they can get a picture of me from 1995
where I'm wearing like a loincloth
horrible embarrassing picture that I
didn't even know existed and I'm like
why they're like I don't know it's
horrible but sign it I still signed the
the Team America puppet great more up in
the night they go can you please sign it
man
yes okay yeah